je revis un passage douloureux
lequel je ne pouvais pas échappé elle a
subi les coups de son mari pendant des
années qu'on en parle je voulais
c'était pas possible en 1975 michel
témoigne à la télé ils me frappaient
même devant les enfants qui pleuraient
ou qu'ils se sauvent et chez la voisine
criant 46 ans plus tard à l'âge de 98
ans elle revient sur son témoignage l'un
des premiers à visage découvert mon
avocat avait demandé un journaliste de
m'interviewer donc je n'ai pas pu y
échapper
cet interrogatoire ce que j'aurais
préféré s'était passé à noah nommément
comme d'autres et ne rien dire il de
garder tout en silence son calvaire a
duré 16 ans j'étais obligé de me coiffer
comme il le désirait de m'habiller comme
il voulait de ne rien faire
en dehors de lui sans quoi j'étais
soumises à des sanctions il commençait à
faire des scènes à me frapper au passage
à m'arracher les cheveux à la vie
n'était pas tenable la justice de ce
temps là était que vous étiez mal mariée
vous n'aviez qu'à terminer votre vie
avec je n'avais pas compris que mon
corps non sort était déjà était déjà
tracé michel a tenté d'alerter la police
à plusieurs reprises
il arrachait l'essai de téléphone quand
ils nous voulions
faire cesser la bagarre à la maison et
que la police devait intervenir il
venait à la maison mais mon mari ouvrez
la porte et ils disaient mais qu'est ce
que c'est notre gardien et la police en
daley se contenter de venir et de
repartir après des années de violences
michel a fini par divorcer en 1978
à l'époque dans les années 70 les
violences conjugales sont à bout sous
médiatisé voir banaliser une femme
choisie au hasard a fait le récit de son
mariage raté mais dans cette foule
anonyme combien d'autres portes au coeur
une blessure similaire mais aucun droit
en soumission à cette époque là tout à
faire en soumission et beaucoup rond
n'ont pas pu échapper
en 2020 en france 139 1200 femmes ont
été victimes de violences conjugales
sont deux d'entre elles sont mortes sous
les coups de leur conjoint je veux dire
à cette génération qu'il faut éduquer
les enfants dans le droit chemin avec de
l'autorité
de la dona de la tendresse pour les
prompts à faire parvenir à faire des
hommes et des femmes voilà
[Musique]